une amende de 700 euros requise contre
le journaliste aboaf jugé aujourd'hui
pour outrage et rébellion envers un
policier
l affaire remonte au 11 juin 2019 le
journaliste avait été interpellé alors
qu'il filmait une manifestation de son
papier à alfortville en région
parisienne jugé aujourd'hui au tribunal
correctionnel de créteil taboye fsa
avait déposé plainte en en assurant avec
un officiel avait blessé à l'épaule
écoutez l'intéressé et son avocat au
micro de charles beaudry ce jus de mer a
continué à mentir et à maintenir les
procès verbaux malgré les vidéos édition
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une forme de
raisonnement totalitaires dans dance
dans cette présentation tant de monsieur
de merck 2
geslin de police que de son avocat que
du ministère public qui a réclamé une
condamnation sur l'autre âge mais pas
sur la rébellion on a l'impression de ne
pas avoir gardé la même vidéo ni de ne
pas avoir entendu les mêmes choses et
après effectivement un problème cognitif
dans cette histoire
l'état voit ce qu'il a envie de voir et
il crée sa propre vérité
les fonctionnaires de police également
j'ai été agressé par un policier de la
bac maxime demers j'ai écopé de dix
jours d'itt et et je me faire opérer de
l'épaule j'ai eu trois semaines d'arrêt
et c'est moi qui me retrouve depuis deux
ans régulièrement tous les deux mois les
procédures envoyé sur le banc des
accusés est en tout cas c'est sûr je
suis heureux que on ait pu débattre sur
le fond de la faire puisqu'on voit qu'en
fait le fond de la faire il est vide on
a des mensonges du policier maxime
demers et d'autres ainsi que tous ses
collègues du début à la fin